que les jeux commencent à ses sept
attrapés la lumière je sais jamais vous
y arriverez les bateaux ont maintenant
pas la lumière
j'aimerais mettre un commentaire mais
devenir appareils elle y c'est drôle
cette année est ce que tu as déjà vu
comme ça jamais la magie qui leur fait
prendre vie s'affaiblit débit et dexter
ils se comportent tous bizarrement mais
qu'est ce que tu fais je prends pas tu
t'es sa faute au hamois la riche
pardonne le pauvre petit singe innocent
et n'a qu'une seule nuit
ces gens-là compte sur moi pour les
sauver tous
tout pourrait disparaître et ne jamais
revenir il faut qu'on aille à londres
pour régler ça tu seras perdu sans nous
jugantor dormait pas
voilà bienvenue au british muséum l'aï
délits du musée d'histoire naturelle de
new york ça doit être trop mortel de
bosser dans la sécurité on américain
avec vos flingue avec les silencieux
avec les épées ninja sauf que tout ça
est complètement bidon et dit un homme
précieux en cas de crise a dit la saed
les muscles pas barbant je suis pas ton
papa oui on se ressemblent pas
pas touche tu arrêtes le musée va se
réveiller pour la première fois et on ne
sait pas du tout ce qui va se passer
je pense qu'on peut affirmer qu'on ait
tant d'autres à le demander sir lancelot
à votre service et honneur aux us
président des états unis d'amérique
ce n'est carrément rien compris nous
serons tous morts à l'aube nous
disparaîtrons a jamais rien ne panique
pas
je suis à la couette vie goûter et
reconnaissant pas la peine d'en rajouter
est-ce que ça fait toujours le chef il
n'est pas le chef on le suit tout
simplement oui c'est bien ce que je
voulais dire
abba
jamais avoir peur de gauche adressait un
bon jour on peut me dire au mausolée la
nuit au musée
le secret des pharaons tu sais ce que tu
as à faire c'est ça assure-toi qu'elle
reste dedans
ces revenus ne les fait sortir qu'est ce
que vous regardez un vous avez jamais vu
une nana canon de votre vie aurait pu
être moins de 15 si elle aimait pas les
pizzas fond le 4 février